After Game of Thrones, Jason Mamoa felt
pigeonholed, not for his incredible
physique and rakish good looks, but
for his grasp…of the English language?
Since Game of Thrones aired its first season
back in 2011, Jason Momoa has gathered a massive
following due to his performance as Khal
Drogo, a warlord of the Dothraki warriors.
Game of Thrones itself became a monumental hit
as well, arguably one of the biggest shows to
ever air. As for Momoa, Drogo wasn't his first
significant role, as he also played the lead in
2011's Conan the Barbarian, along with his first
ever credited role on the original Baywatch.
If you haven't seen Momoa in these two
early roles, or even in Game of Thrones,
you have likely seen him star as
Aquaman in the DC Universe movies,
or his Apple TV+ series See. He also played
the famed character of Duncan Idaho in the
2021 Dune film adaptation. Suffice it to say,
the actor has amassed a great resume. Given
how popular the star has become in both the
film and TV space, you might be surprised to
know that one of these roles nearly stunted his
rise to the top — and, no, it isn't Baywatch.
"I'm me. One thing. One piece.
One person. All together."
As Jason Momoa spoke about in an interview
with Jimmy Fallon on The Tonight Show,
the actor's breakout role as Khal Drogo in Game
of Thrones actually hampered his career, rather
than boosting it. Apparently, his performance as
Drogo — particularly his adept handling of the
fictional Dothraki language — was so convincing
that many people in the entertainment industry
thought that Momoa couldn't speak English that
well, which "pigeonholed" him, as Momoa put it.
Momoa went on to recall an encounter with
actor Fred Armisen. They met because Momoa's
stepdaughter Zoë Kravitz acted in Portlandia.
Momoa said that Armisen professed how much he was
a fan of his performance in Game of Thrones, but
that he hadn't known that the actor spoke English.
"It was heartbreaking. I was like,
'That's why I'm not getting any jobs.'"
Fortunately for Momoa, Zack Snyder was
an even bigger fan of his than Armisen,
and the director soon called Momoa to come in
to audition for a vaguely described DC movie,
supposedly for the role of Batman. Weeks later,
Snyder offered Momoa the role of Aquaman instead,
and the rest is history. Thankfully, it's pretty
clear to mainstream Hollywood now that Momoa is
a native English speaker. Nonetheless, the
actor's ability to speak other languages,
especially the fictional kind,
is clearly better than most.
Knowing that Jason Momoa struggled to break out
of his typecast image for years after amassing
popularity in Game of Thrones is heartbreaking
enough, but the portrait the actor paints of
his life during this time is even darker. In an
interview with InStyle, Momoa revealed that during
the period between Game of Thrones and his casting
as Aquaman, he struggled to support his family,
including his two newborn children and his
then-wife Lisa Bonet. Momoa told the outlet:
Even while he was still filming for Game of
Thrones, Momoa was already contending with
financial troubles. In a 2019 Instagram post, the
actor recalled a story from when the mega-popular
series had paused production in Ireland and
he couldn't afford a flight home. Not one to
wallow in a bad situation, however, Momoa seized
the opportunity to go on a cross-country road
trip with his friend, film producer Brian
Andrew Mendoza. Momoa wrote in the caption:
While Momoa may have struggled during this
early-career period, it's nice to know
that the actor still looks back on his time
filming Game of Thrones with some fondness.